la justice allemande va se pencher sur
une affaire qui embarrasse le pouvoir
saoudien dans une plante de plusieurs
centaines de pages adressée au procureur
général de la cour constitutionnelle
fédérale de karlsruhe et reporters sans
frontières accuse plusieurs hauts
responsables saoudiens de persécuter
systématiquement les journalistes cette
juridiction jouit notamment d'une
compétence universelle qui lui permet de
juger certains crimes commis à
l'étranger et elle va donc devoir se
prononcer sur une plainte qui met
directement en cause le tout-puissant
prince héritier mohammed bin salman
il est accusé entre autres de torture de
violence ou de disparitions forcées
exercée contre 34 journalistes
nous demandons une analyse de la
situation en vue d'ouvrir de manière
officielle
une enquête du ministère public qui
serait une première mondiale
avant d'émettre ensuite des mandats
d'arrêt cette nouvelle accusation contre
eux mbs s'ajoutent aux conclusions de l
enquête des services secrets américains
sur son rôle présumé dans l'assassinât
du journaliste jamal racho 10 pour
washington c'est bien lui qui a donné le
feu vert à l'opération
le prince héritier d'arabie saoudite
mohamed ben salman à valider une
opération à istanbul en turquie pour
capturer ou tuer le journaliste saoudien
jamal rachid
après avoir nié son assassinat ryad a
reconnu que plusieurs agents saoudiens
avaient tué jamal arrache audi en
octobre 2018 dans le consulat d'arabie
saoudite à istanbul
le journaliste critique envers le
pouvoir saoudien s'était exilé aux états
unis avant de collaborer avec le
washington post
selon le renseignement américain une
vingtaine de personnes dont l'ancien
directeur adjoint des renseignements
généraux saoudiens sont impliqués dans
cette opération
les etats unis ont annoncé des sanctions
financières contre plusieurs
responsables saoudiens 76 personnes sont
désormais interdites de séjour aux états
unis le prince héritier lui n'est pas
concerné par ces mesures restrictives
le royaume wahhabite continue de rejeter
les accusations contre eux en baisse
nous n'avons pas besoin d'être soulagé
parce que nous n'avons jamais pensé que
c'était une possibilité sérieuse
le prince héritier n'est pas impliqué
dans ce processus et a été innocenté de
tout acte répréhensible
il a endossé la responsabilité morale en
tant que dirigeant courageux et cela
signifie veiller à ce que la situation
soit rectifiée et les responsables de ce
crime odieux traduits en justice la
justice saoudienne a condamné huit des
accusés à des peines de prison mais
aucun responsable de premier plan c'est
dans ce contexte que le président
américain s'est entretenu la semaine
dernière au téléphone avec le roi salman
le souverain qui a insisté pour
maintenir un partenariat solide avec les
états unis selon le classement mondial
de la liberté de la presse établi par
rsf
l'arabie saoudite occupe le 70e rang sur
180 pays